protesters tear down statues of great
Americans while the editor of the 16:19
project shears them on shootings
breakout in major cities across the
United States and President Trump throws
a sort of party in Tulsa I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the bench Bureau show the Ben
Shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action and Express VPN calm slash Ben
are they got a ton to get to today I
mean like I a lot to get you today we'll
get to all of it in just one second
first let us talk about a simple fact
these days you're sitting at home a lot
and perhaps one of the things you've
forgotten to do is brush your teeth I
know it's one of those things it sounds
small but it's actually quite large
because if you don't brush your teeth
that actually has implications for all
of your health good health means
starting with good habits and quit makes
it easy by delivering all the oral care
essentials you need to brush and floss
better the clip electric toothbrush has
timed sonic vibrations with 30 second
pulses it's a guide a dentist
recommended 2 minute routine there's
even a size down version just for kids
prepared with quips handset cavity
toothpaste and mint or watermelon you
get all the ingredients teeth actually
need and none they don't also very often
you know if you go to the grocery store
and buy the parts then you forget the
parts like another 30 days later it's a
problem right now you're using an old
brush head or you run out of floss and
for a week you don't have the floss
that's never going to happen again with
quip quip a brush head toothpaste and
floss refills are automatically
delivered on a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just
five bucks each a friendly reminder when
it's time for a refresh and to stay
committed to your oral health and
shipping is free to an over 3 million
happy customers practice good oral care
and if you go to get clipped comm slash
appear oh right now get your first
refill for free again that's get quip
comm slash prep muezzin clip for years
that's your first refill free at get
quip comm slashing Shapiro GE tqu IP
comm slash Shapiro quip the good habits
company ok so I'm sure that back in high
school somebody forced you to read 1984
by George Orwell you may not remember it
that well but one of the key components
of 1984 is this idea that the party
write the entire book is about the
community communist party in Russia but
obviously it's disguised as sometime in
the future in the West in 1984 one of
the one of the key components of the
party is the attempt to
right history and rewrite reality it is
a key component right all dissenting
views must be quashed and history must
be rewritten there's a part one
character is explaining to another
character exactly what the party does in
order to rewrite reality in the minds of
its constituents and this character says
do you realize that the past starting
from yesterday has it been actually
abolished if it survives anywhere it's
in a few solid objects with no words
attached to them like that lump of glass
there already we know almost literally
nothing about the Revolution and the
years before the Revolution every record
has been destroyed or falsified every
book has been rewritten every picture
has been repainted every statue and
Street and building has been renamed
every date has been altered and that
process is continuing day by day and
minute by minute
history has stopped nothing exists
except an endless present in which the
party is always right I know of course
the past is falsified but it would never
be possible for me to prove it even when
I did the falsification myself after the
thing is done no evidence ever remains
the only evidence is inside my own mind
and I don't know with any certainty that
any other human being shares my memories
so in other words the constant rewriting
of history is necessary in order for
perpetual revolution to continue because
of course if people remember the past if
people remember that not all the
principles being espoused by the party
in 1984 are right or are actually in
concert with reality or history then it
presents a threat to the party and so
all of history must be wiped away all of
history must be rewritten we have to
relaunch at Year Zero and we are seeing
this from today's revolutionaries and I
am not exaggerating here the goal of
many people on the what I've called in
my book that disintegration is left the
goal of many of those people is to
destroy all icons of American history to
destroy American history itself and this
is why you see in San Francisco's Golden
Gate Park the tearing down of a wide
variety of statues including statues of
people who are deeply instrumental in
ending slavery and fighting the the anti
reconstruction south so ulysses s grant
who is now being sort of in in
revisionist fashion thought of is a very
very good president originally he was
thought of as not a great president
because of corruption and venality
supposedly during his administration it
turns out a lot of that history had been
written by people who are sort of
sympathetic to the south ulysses s grant
is now seeing
is not only the general who smashed the
Confederacy but also the president who
helped try to implement reconstruction
in a way that preserved the rights of
black southerners and the end of his
presidency men the end of reconstruction
efforts in America for a hundred years
it was really a tragedy the end of his
presidency the Reconstructionist
Republicans the Radical Republicans were
basically ousted from power about the
same time as ulysses s grant Ulysses s
grant is a great hero of American
history we're not talking here about
taking down robert e lee's statues which
is controversial in and of itself we're
certainly not talking about taking down
nathan bedford forrest statues right the
founder the KKK talking about taking
down the statues of the guy who is the
most instrumental general in destroying
the slaveholding Confederacy and the
morons I would say well you know maybe
they're not morons because again they
have an agenda but the the I would say
the the moral fools on the on the
radical left have decided that even
statues of ulysses s grant have to be
taken down according to the hill while
grant is widely celebrated as being one
of the leading forces who helped the
Union win the Civil War bringing an end
to slavery in the United States some
historians have pointed to his
complicated relationship with slavery
because as we know most people did not
have a complicated relationship with
slavery in 1859 it slavery wasn't a
thing in 1859 protestors in San
Francisco on Friday toppled the statue
of former President Grant San Francisco
police said approximately 400 people
gathered around 8:00 p.m. to take down
the statue and no arrests were made
where exactly are the cops during office
where is the law in order that we were
promised exactly from the White House
where exactly does this perpetual
revolution end all so torn down in the
park the statues of st. Junipero Serra
and Francis Scott Key who wrote the
lyrics to the star-spangled banner and
people on the Left are really hesitant
to condemn any of this that I've seen
very little upset over the taking down
of the statue of Junipero Serra despite
the fact that Joe Biden was on tape and
says Nancy Pelosi
standing in front of a statue of st.
Junipero Serra I believe what the Pope a
few years back because of course he is a
Catholic saint the grant statue coming
down is really the key right because
when you talk about Junipero Serra you
could at least make the case that he
treated the the natives badly but even
Junipero Serra he's really in line with
Columbus right the idea here is that
when what
people's came to the new world that they
destroyed the new world on the back of
the Western imperialism because of
course imperialism colonialism and evil
never existed until the West arrived in
the new world but ok Junipero Serra who
is the founder of the mission system in
in California on behalf of the Spanish
government his stature was taken down
they went after a statue of Cervantes
which doesn't even make sense
restaurantes Lee I wrote Don Quixote
Cervantes was held as a slave for 5
years then went after his statue anyway
because they don't know anything didn't
know who this guy was they just saw a
white guy and so they decided to deface
his statue was the basic idea here but
the taking town of the statue of grant
is so telling because again grant is a
figure who stood against slavery
grants is a figure whose instrumental in
destroying the Confederacy grant stands
for all the things that the protesters
say they stood for at least if you're
looking at his public image but he has
to be taken down too because all of
American history has to be rewritten not
as the story of a country struggling to
overcome the evils of human nature
struggling to overcome its own inability
to fulfill its founding principles
instead the country has to be rewritten
as evil from founding and the only good
people who have ever lived make no
mistake the only good people who have
ever lived are leftists from the radical
sixties on everybody else in human
history was bad everybody from the
nineteen sixties on who was radical was
good and even the sixties radicals were
not radical enough and they must be
thrown out of the universities today
they were still a little bit too liberal
the radicals from the 1960s because they
they used to say things like we want to
live a life beyond color in the United
States we want to live a life where race
doesn't matter in the United States see
even that is inherently racist and so
even they are not good the only people
who are good are the people who read the
16:19 project and think that it
represents all of American history the
only people who are good today are the
the anti-racists pushed forward by
Ibrahim candy right those are the only
people who are good in the United States
today they live right now isn't it
amazing to live at this time when the
only good people live right know good
people have ever lived before and if you
took those people who are good today and
you plop them down in 1850 they would
believe exactly the same things they
believe today in 1850 dude and out there
in the streets stumping for transgender
rights and gay marriage and for anti
racism of the mold that talks about how
if you say that you are colorblind and
you are totally
in favor of the Equality of races then
that's not enough right did they would
they would have exactly the same
politics today as if they were plopped
down in 1500 because history doesn't
matter right history doesn't exist the
only thing that matters is that the only
moral people who live now are the people
who are in charge of our cultural
revolution we're gonna get to the
ideological basis for this because it's
very clear okay this is not happening in
a vacuum and the people who are pushing
it forward are deeply deeply dishonest
they're honest about their own desire to
tear down the country they are deeply
dishonest about what exactly they are
saying because what they're saying is
just a pack of lies we're gonna get to
that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that maybe these
days you're tearing out your own hair or
maybe you're just one of the two out of
three dudes he's going to experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they are 35 the best way to
prevent hair loss is to do something
about it well I still have hair left
because once the hair is gone probably
ain't coming back all that easily
prevention is key keeps will help you
make sure that your hair is not lost
they make it easy they deliver your
medication every three months you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor's visits you can
visit the doctor online and get hair
loss medication delivered right to your
door keeps treatments can take up to
four to six months or more to see
results so it is important to act fast
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you will save find out why
keeps has more 5-star reviews than any
of its competitors nearly 100,000 men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication keeps treatments
start at just ten bucks a month plus for
a limited time you can get your first
month for free I've been using keeps
myself because male pattern baldness
does run in the family I'd like to keep
the hair that I have if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps calm slash Ben to receive your
first month of treatment for free that
is ke EPS calm slash but if you want to
keep a magnificent head of hair like
this one make sure that you go check out
keeps calm slash man that is ke e PS
calm slash man keeps calm slash Ben so
they tore down a statue of grant
suggesting of course that grant wasn't
abolitionist enough again only
responsible for the breaking of the back
of the Confederacy only responsible for
overseeing the Radical Republican
attempts at reconstruction but bad guy
bad guy know what's amazing is that some
semi sane people on the Left will push
back against the radicals but many will
not so Adam sir war who writes for the
Atlantic and is definitely a member of
the hardcore left
he says granted briefly owned one slave
he freed years before the war but as a
general he smashed the Confed
see as president he crushed the clan he
presided over the ratification of the
Fifteenth Amendment people going after
Grant probably just want to break things
and Matthew Iglesias right who I've
called the Ralph Wiggum of the internet
right around huge Matthew Iglesias fan
although he has been kind of cudgelled
into sanity over the last several months
but you're seeing him start to crack
back against some of the the insanity of
the censorious left he he tweeted out
feels like this is slippery slope
overreach but here is the thing here is
the thing there is a group of
intellectuals who actually believe in
this stuff Nicole Hannah Jones is the
leader of this cadre Nicole Hannah Jones
is the creator of the 16:19 project now
you've heard me rip on the 16:19 project
since inception because the 16:19
project when we talk about that 1984
rewriting of dates and restarting of
history and rewriting of history
she is Exhibit A in this first of all
she won a Pulitzer Prize for bad history
that's literally what you want to feel
the surprise for so she want a peel a
surprise she brags about it her history
was so bad that the New York Times had
to correct it
she was chided by no less than three
other pillars her prize-winning
historians because her history was not
good and she basically creates things
had a whole cloth like she says things
online there's just a historical in the
extreme she'll say that the Second
Amendment is founded in white supremacy
and pro-slavery which of course is not
even close to true it's not even close
to true okay but that is her contention
she was put in she's basically been
handed the keys to the car over at the
New York Times to the point where she
has the capacity basically to ask the
editorial page editor if she's angry the
editorial page editor for running an
editorial by Senator Tom cotton
she's been granted the keys to the car
has it has this lady and she's very bad
at her job but she is is not like one of
the more sane members of the left who
say maybe we're going a little too far
her guys when were tearing down statues
of ulysses s grant instead she's kind of
like okay with it she's kind of okay
with it so to understand why she's okay
with it you first have to understand
that she's okay with the general
ideology of tearing down American
history in fact she thinks it's good she
wants American history torn down from
inception so we can rewrite history as
the story of cruelty evil and malice and
then we can tear down all of America's
institutions remember as I talked about
last week there has been a shift on the
left from in the definition of racism
itself racism in the 1960s was seen as
an obstacle
that once overcome would free all
Americans to have equal rights under the
law is provided by the Declaration of
Independence and the Constitution of the
United States
this was the MLK definition of racism
and Martin Luther King definition of
racism is there are racist policies that
deliberately target one group of people
that races people who deliberately
target one group of people and if we can
stop those people and those policies
then freedom will have been granted and
now you have individual agency to pursue
your lives then in the 1960s late 1960s
early 1970s the definition of racism
itself shifted and suddenly it went from
racism is an obstacle to be overcome to
racism is the system the system equals
racism there's an equal sign there and
that means the only way to get rid of
racism is to tear down the system itself
all institutions of the system are
inherently white supremacists the only
way to tear down the white supremacy of
the system is to tear down the system
itself they're inextricable it is not
that the systems are good and were
plagued by the problem and evil of white
supremacy is that white supremacy
created the system's white supremacy
maintains the systems and even if you
stop the openly racist policies even if
you stop the open racists from pursuing
their goals the system itself was
constructed by people who are racist and
therefore can never be fixed this is it
it's it's the same sort of ideology that
suggests that you have to tear down the
art of artists because they had bad
personal lives because they came from
exactly the same place so all of the
institutions have to be destroyed
because the institutions themselves were
bad and the reason they were bad is they
were founded by people who were white
supremacists and racists and you've seen
this you know across like there is no
limits of this principle no limit at all
I mean the New York Museum of Natural
History has now announced they're going
to take down a statue of Teddy Roosevelt
not kidding there's a statue of Teddy
Roosevelt that's coming down so the the
Roosevelt who you know interned
several hundred thousand
japanese-americans those statues are
still up at Teddy Roosevelt is being
removed from the Museum of Natural
History
why because supposedly his a symbol of
colonialism and racism I'm looking
forward to seeing all the Woodrow Wilson
monuments coming up but Teddy Roosevelt
is bad to everyone is bad right all all
people in history are bad the museum
took action according to the New York
Times amid a heated national debate over
the appropriateness of statues or
monuments that first focused on
Confederate symbols like robert e lee
and has now moved on to a wider arc of
from Christopher Columbus to Winston
Churchill namely everyone namely
everyone is remember last week a Kratz
had fired to a statue of George
Washington okay so to get back to the
1619 projects and their goals they're
not being there not being closed about
this they're not being subtle about any
of this okay so there is an article in
The New York Times called call them the
1619 riots and the basic idea is the
idea that I have been promulgating here
which is that a lot of the people who
are rioting and looting are under the
wildness impression pushed forward by
those on the radical left in academia in
the media that America is inherently and
forever evil and must be torn down from
its roots and that includes George
Washington that includes Thomas
Jefferson that includes everybody this
is not restricted to the evils of the
Confederacy this is not restricted to
the evils of slavery we have to tear
down Washington because he was the slave
holder we have to turn on Jefferson
because he was a slave holder we have to
tear down Grant because he held a slave
for a year we have to tear down everyone
Teddy Roosevelt has to come down
everyone has to come down everyone
Cervantes has that like everyone has to
come down ok so there was that article
New York Post called called them the
1619 riots and Nicole Hannah Jones who's
the creator of the of the 1619 project
right she tweeted back it would be an
honor thank you again the picture that
was featured in this tweet is a picture
of a statue of George Washington on the
ground I believe is that George
Washington on the ground that may okay
the story itself is about the tearing
down of the statue of George Washington
at least that much is fair the story
talks about the destruction of very
that's a Thomas Jefferson statue I'm
sorry this is a band and on it is
painted slave-owner and of course if you
look at that torn down statue of George
Washington people had spray-painted
16:19 on the statute because the idea is
that the true founding remember that
that quote from Orwell the true founding
the true date that matters is 1619 and
not 1776 not 1865
be true the true story of America is
1619 forever and always and it doesn't
matter what intervening events have
happened it doesn't matter what has
happened to vitiate any of that doesn't
matter how many Americans died in order
to rectify the founding vision of the
United States doesn't matter 600,000
Americans died in the Civil War
doesn't matter that literally million
of white Americans had to back the civil
rights movement in order for the civil
white rights movement to actually take
effect may the the the real history of
the United States is instead one of
racial conflict in which black Americans
were the only people this is literally
something to call Hannah Jones is
basically said meant black people were
the only people who are basically
standing against the tyranny of America
forever and always because America is
evil and has to be torn down so she
tweets out it would be an honor to call
these the 16:19 riots an honor to call
these the sixty nineteen riots the
rioting and the looting and the tearing
down of American statutes we'll get more
into this viewpoint which is pernicious
and nasty and quite evil for the United
States we'll get into that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that going to the post office right now
probably not a good idea
it was never all that great to go to the
post office I mean lots of great
services there but did you really want
to wait in line well now the idea of
schlepping boxes to the post office and
then waiting in line at the post office
in a closed space probably not the best
idea instead why you just do all of this
from home and save money in the process
here at Ailey where we've been using
stamps calm since 2017 we will not waste
our time stamps calm offers UPS services
- with discounts up to 62 percent no UPS
residential surcharges stamps calm will
bring all the services of the US Postal
Service directly to your computer in the
safety and comfort of your own home
office or anywhere else you are
hunkering down right now whether you're
a small business sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
you're just working from home and need
to mail stuff stamps calm can handle it
all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just leave it for your mail
carrier schedule a free package pick up
or drop it in a mailbox no human contact
is required it is indeed phat simple
stamps calm is a no-brainer especially
right now it saves you time it saves you
money and it will keep you safe in these
insane times if you've got a way to save
money why wouldn't you do it right now
my listeners get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage ends digital scale no long term
commitment just head on over to stamps
com click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in at Shapiro
that is stamps calm and use that code
Shapiro type it in at the top of the
homepage where the microphone is again
stamps calm and use a code Shapiro for
that special deal ok so Nicole Hannah
Jones again makes very very clear
exactly what it is she is after here she
doesn't just weed out that is an honor
to have been the the creator of a
project that has been used as the
ideological basis for the tearing down
of all American history she doesn't we
taught about Ulysses s Koran so as I say
some people on the left and again Adam
somewhere is a man on the Left he says
yeah we might be going a little far with
the square and stuff Matthew glaces
maybe going a little bit far with this
grand stuff Nicole Hanna Jones again the
69 team project Pulitzer Prize winner
for an essay so bad it had to be
corrected by the New York Times
she writes I think maybe grants is not a
statue worth toppling I think maybe
maybe it's not a statue worth toppling
it's not that it's bad to topple the
statute south it's a moral evil or a
blot it's the top of the statue of a man
who is the chief the chief architect of
the destruction of the Confederacy and
the guy behind the Fifteenth Amendment
and the guy behind the radical
reconstruction attempt to to stop the
KKK no no and maybe it's just not worth
it you know guys maybe maybe we
shouldn't bother she says I also
understand after decades of shrugs when
people spoke of the hurt of having been
too mean by public tributes of entering
buildings of walking past art that
celebrated white supremacy how
overzealous how overzealousness occurs
oh so it's just overzealousness tearing
down the grand statues that's what it's
just a little overzealous guys don't you
understand you know you ignored it when
they wanted to tear down all of the
statues of like robert e lee and Nathan
Bedford Forrest and you can see how
people would be like you know upset and
so tear down the person who destroyed
Robert Elia Nathan Bedford Forrest yeah
that makes perfect sense
I know that when when people say to me
you know Ben you know you you're going
too hard after the commies my first
reaction is to burn an American flag
because that makes perfect sense I just
go directly after the people who are
also going after the people I was going
after that makes perfect sense I hit my
friends that's that's exactly my point
you know when you when you stop people
from taking down statues of Confederates
well I mean you can see why they would
get overzealous and then take down
statues of Union generals this makes
perfect sense if you are an idiot okay
that's not only what she said she says
there was plenty of time to reckon
before this moment people who are not
too graded into mean by public art and
didn't think it was important think it
that important and now people want to
control which are righteous and which
are not statues torn down can be put
back up but the reckoning is here and
that of course is the point the
reckoning has no limits the reckoning is
here guys and we can't we can't condemn
people for being overzealous and to
facing
statues of ulysses s grant or tearing
down statues of Thomas Jefferson and
George Washington are talking about
renaming Columbus Ohio flavor ttan which
what is this a parody and so that's
literally a thing people that there's a
petition of thousands of people they
signed a petition to rename Columbus
Ohio because it's named after Columbus
Christopher Columbus lead the evil evil
man who brought Western civilization to
the new world right the there's a
petition to rename Columbus Ohio
flavortown
after a guy fieri which meant because
I'm sure Guy Fieri has never sinned and
also I think that his contribution to
the world is definitely on par I mean I
don't know much about guy theory but I
feel like his contribution to Western
civilization is directly on par with the
Explorer who found the New World on
behalf of Western civilization it makes
perfect sense makes perfect sense guys
by the way Columbia University I look
forward to them renaming themselves that
should be really exciting as well okay
and then Nicole Hannah Jones continues
perhaps this gives us the opportunity to
stop deifying men who like all human
beings were terribly flawed and so
instead provide an opportunity for a
reckoning that does not obscure the
complexities of nation built on ideals
of freedom and the practice of slavery
okay but couldn't you do that with the
Statue standing because it seems like
the purpose of the statues would be to
jog conversation about the person and
also that is a case for removing
Confederate statues it is not a case for
removing Union statues or the statues of
the founders see a nuanced history would
allow the statutes to stand as a point
Condoleezza Rice has made now I will say
it is it is sort of hilarious she also
has suggested by the way that we should
not contextualize people it's very bad
to contextualise people she said I'm
sick of hearing that you will cease as
grant was a man of his times ulysses s
grant wasn't you know a man of his times
his phraseology that's bad it's bad
phraseology
why is it bad phraseology well because
it justifies people's behavior and then
she goes on and she says you know it
wasn't just it wasn't just grants was a
man of his time Hitler was a man of his
time Hitler was a man of his time is is
something that she actually says this
person want appeal in surprise Hitler
was a man of his time is a thing that
she actually tweeted she said I'm not
advocating against nuance and balance I
am saying that particular phrase is just
really offensive I mean Hitler was a man
of his time Osama bin Laden was
a man of his time it's a justification
and they're necessary okay first of all
I feel like Hitler was a man of his time
is not quite the same thing as George
Washington was a man of his time right
Hitler was if you're telling me that in
1941 nobody knew the genocide and
millions of people was wrong as opposed
to in 1770 slavery was the rule rather
than the exception around planet Earth
right that a man of his time and suggest
that this was a commonly held view point
and that most people sort of were okay
with it even though it was evil of time
that's a man of his time Hitler was very
much not a man of his time when it came
to you know Jena citing millions of
people Osama bin Laden was not exactly a
man of his time
Osama bin Laden flew planes into the
World Trade Centers it was kind of
outrageous you may remember because we
were alive during that one does anybody
think Oh 2001 yeah that was that time
when people just flew planes into
buildings it was just a thing it was a
man of his time you know something a lot
a man of his time
this person is she's a fool she's a fool
she's a moral she's a moral idiot and
this person was rewarded with that with
the Pulitzer Prize man of his time my
favorite is that she says I'm not
against nuance and balance but we can't
we can't say man of his time because
it's a bad phrase a bad phrase by the
way unless you're saying that Fidel
Castro is a man of his time just a
couple years back she was defending
Fidel Castro she was suggesting one can
look at Castro his treatment of dissent
and economic woes in a vacuum as if the
United States did not play a huge role
in both this is November of 2016
defending Fidel Castro man of his time
this is what I've screwed about is
asking for sophisticated nuanced view of
Castro period so she so yes on the
sophisticated nuance view of Castro no
on the sophisticated nuanced view of
George Washington Thomas Jefferson and
ulysses s grant know on that this person
I mean this is just dole t'ish stuff it
seriously is it's Tolton stuff well done
new york times for putting this person
on a pedestal and making her the arbiter
of history she's one of the only good
people in human history it's pretty
amazing she gets to sit there and judge
everybody else in human history outside
the context of their time and she can
actually determine that Fidel Castro was
not only a fidel castro was cut so what
we've gotten from her is it Fidel Castro
it was a man of his time it in a good
way right we have to put him in with
contextualise Fidel Castro but if we're
talking about you know Thomas Jefferson
George Washington you
he says grant stop saying men of their
time because Hitler was a man of his
time and bin Laden was a man of his time
what absolute sheer nonsense and this
person want to kill it surprise by the
way that's the only thing that matters
to her obviously somebody tweeted at her
you literally had to post a correction
for a piece that won't appeal it sir
and you're gonna preach to others about
studying up on history by a mirror
sweetheart and she wrote and she wrote
back then won a Pulitzer yes you did win
a Pulitzer
because the Pulitzer Prizes have become
a demented shadow of themselves it's
pathetic okay so what is the end goal
here the end goal as it was in 1984 is
the perpetual revolution there cannot be
an endpoint there cannot be any sort of
actual end point okay and not only can
there not be any sort of end point click
further note on Nicole Hannah Jones this
person is so all-fired virtuous that she
implied last night that fireworks that
were being set off starting about 8:00
p.m. ending that's who I am in Brooklyn
we're actually in attempt I'm not
kidding you we're an attempt to scare
black and brown people maybe promoted by
the government this is serious you
tweeted out she tweet us just asking
questions you guys okay so here's the
thing many of us on the right we think
that Alex Jones is ridiculous person
meetings ridiculous person like Alex
Jones should not be up for the peel it
sir but this lady just won the Pulitzer
and she is literally tweeting out that
people setting off fireworks until 2:00
a.m. is probably white supremacist
trying to scare black and brown people I
can tell you I live in Los Angeles
people been setting off fireworks every
single night for weeks every single
night for weeks until all hours of the
morning I'm fairly certain it is not a
government-sponsored threat to black and
brown people the most intelligent wisest
being out there okay so what exactly are
people after they are after the
perpetual revolution the perpetual
revolution and for white leftists this
feels good because all you have to do is
disassociate from the key institutions
of the United States and from the key
key ideologies of the United States and
then you will be good again
don't you understand you'll be good
again this is how you end up with Robyn
D'Angelo being trotted out by all of
these major publications has some sort
of experts on white racism and white
fragility by the way white lady getting
rich off of racism is really an ironic
thing it's pretty incredible and she's
out selling Tana hosta coats right now
which is pretty impressed
here she is Robyn D'Angelo she's being
quoted by NPR she's with interrupts the
systems we live within okay I don't even
what the hell that means what does that
mean to interrupt the system is that
even in English how do you interrupt the
system the hell are you talking about
she's using deliberately vague language
so that the standards are fungible and
changeable because if you say listen I
condemned that that's not interrupting
the system you have to interrupt the
system okay well I tore down a statue is
that enough maybe that's enough
here's Robyn D'Angelo author of white
fragility who is a crazy person and is
being trotted out because again one of
the goals here is to be deliberately
vague you have to understand that when
it comes to talking about racism one of
the goals is it used to be the old
definition of racism you could be very
very specific about what was racist you
know is racist a Jim Crow law that was
racist it explicitly said black people
are not allowed to do this thing that
white people are allowed to do you used
to be able to say this person is a
racist this person will not do for a
black person what he would do for a
white person now the standards have
changed and the reason the standards
have changed is because so long as you
keep the standards changing all that
exists is the party all that exists is
the new standard it's not that the
goalposts are moving is the goal posts
never existed the goal posts this is
Lucy with the football and the minute
you give in to the radical left that is
the minute that they've got you by the
nose and they can just pull you anywhere
they want by the nose it's an incredible
here's Robyn D'Angelo saying exactly
this when you back one group's
collective bias with that kind of power
it is transformed into a far-reaching
system it becomes the default it's
automatic it's not dependent on your you
know agreement or belief or approval
it's circulating 24/7 365
so racism is the foundation of the
society we are in and to simply carry on
with absolutely no active interruption
of that system is to be complicit with
it and in that way we can say that nice
white people are racist ah nice white
people who oppose racism are actually
racist because they're not anti racism
and anti racism because the definition
of racism is chimerical and shifting to
be anti-racist means do the things Robyn
D'Angelo says you must do
or Nicole Hannah Jones says you must do
see there is a cadre of woke priests and
you must listen to the world priests
because this is a religion now you have
to listen to the woke priests and if the
woke priests tell you to do a thing and
you don't do the thing this makes you
not anti-racist and therefore racist or
you have to be an activist on behalf of
the people who are constantly changing
the standards they read the chicken
entrails and then they tell you what you
have to do today in order to be
considered not racist in order to be
considered anti-racist and it's not
enough to say I'm against racism because
you see you're only against the old
style of racism but the new definition
of racism which shifts and change and is
miasmatic deliberately so deliberately
vague the goal there is to make sure
that you're constantly at the beck and
call of your woke peers and your walk
matters
that is the goal here and by the way you
know who this makes feel the best of all
it makes feel the best of all you lead
us because those people get to set the
standard you weren't even part of the
priesthood right the priesthood is the
place to be because it also gives you
the responsibility over everyone else
for white woke leftist this is the best
thing right as I mentioned last week
Shelby Steele's written about this what
this means for white won't left woke
white leftist particularly is that they
are better than other white people right
white liberals are bad but woke white
leftists are good because what woke
white leftist get to set the standard
for the other white liberals they're
superior to everybody else in the United
States Robyn D'Angelo is superior to you
she's a better person than you because
she has the decoder ring that she got in
her box of Cracker Jack she has the red
radish is the Red Ryder decoder ring
from Christmas story and she's going to
tell you exactly what you have to do
she's superior to other white people and
she's also this is tacitly said as
Shelby Steele puts it she's superior to
black people in her own mind why because
black people need her guidance black
people need her help
but people have no agency black people
have no independence or freedom in the
United States absent the white people
like Robyn D'Angelo who can sit there
and read the system and interrupt
the systems they need her help
she's very very important now before she
was just some white lady but now she is
super duper important okay this is
dangerous it's dangerous to the country
it's dangerous to black Americans
there's a great column in The Wall
Street Journal today about exactly this
by man named Ian row I'm gonna read it
to I'm gonna talk about it in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that now's not a great time to go over
to the local autozone
in fact never is a great time to go to
the local autozone
we'll probably you're paying too much
money right you go in and they have
different price levels for people who
are professionals or do-it-yourselfers
or they may not have the exact part and
they have to order the exact part or
they just give you some generic parts
that doesn't work all that great instead
head on over to the interwebs and use
Rock auto comm rockauto.com is a lot
easier than walking into a store and
someone demanding quick answers to
things like is your Odyssey and LX or an
ax and then person behind the counter
has to dig behind the counter to find
what you're looking for they probably
don't have it instead head on over to
rockauto.com they always offer the
lowest prices possible rather than
changing prices based on what the market
will bear like airlines do why spend up
to twice as much for the same parts
rockauto.com it's a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds manufacturers best of all
prices of rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the rockauto.com catalog it's
unique it's remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
brands specifications and prices you
prefer amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available right shapiro in there how did
you hear about a spots so they know that
we sent you okay so as I say the Robin
de Angelo a view of the world
Nicole Hannah Jones view of the world
that there is this wolf priesthood that
gets to dictate to the rest of America
exactly how they ought to act and how
they ought to think and has to tear down
all the systems and exactly the way they
say it's incredibly demeaning to
everyone in the country who is not a
member of the priesthood if you're not a
member of the priesthood case then the
priesthood cast and you are you are out
in the wilderness and you must bow
before them right that is the real goal
here this is particularly bad for black
Americans Ian Rowe is a columnist for
The Wall Street Journal he has a piece
called the power of personal agency now
you'll recall I've talked about this at
length that the worst thing that you can
say to somebody in the United States is
your destiny is not in your own hands
that your destiny is in the hands of
Robin to Angelo and a coal Hannah Jones
and all the people who're going to
rewrite the system top to bottom and
we're not talking about systems that are
deliberately designed to keep people
down or so much as general freedom based
equal rights before law systems those
systems and the cells have to be torn
down and then you tell people the way
that Michelle Obama did in her
graduation speech and if you're young
and black in America and you do all the
right things you're still not going to
get ahead that's like the worst thing
you can do so Ian wrote writes herein
lies the great danger of this moment
the next generation of Americans black
and white might grow up believing that
the entire destiny of one race rests in
the hands of another which must first
renounce its privilege before any
progress can be made the potential
damage is that young people are robbed
of their sense of personal agency the
belief and ability that can control
their own destiny he says for the past
decade I've run a network of public
charter schools in the South Bronx and
the Lower East Side of Manhattan our
mission has been to empower the students
we educate mostly from our black or
Hispanic and from low-income houses to
become whatever they want to be
regardless of the actions of any
quote/unquote oppressive majority when
I'm helping young people of all races to
envision what is possible we have to
counter what Tyrone Howard of the
University of California Los Angeles
calls the quote pathological depiction
of and belief in the inferiority of
black people culture and history instead
we must identify and speak about black
excellence especially now when the
prevailing notion seems to be that black
people's efforts are futile in the face
of white supremacy we must accentuate
the positive stories of millions of
black men and women who are living the
American dream or are on their way to do
so despite structural barriers census
data showed that more than three million
black students were enrolled in college
or graduate school in 2018 according to
the Washington Post 23 unarmed black
people were killed by police that year
this is 23 too many yet roughly one
hundred and thirty six thousand black
students were in higher education for
each unarmed black person killed by
police this is their pathways to power
for young black people that's why our
nation's educators must help black girls
and boys cultivate a sense of personal
agency and convinced them that their
deliverance is determined more by their
own actions than by the incantations of
a newly enlightened majority and this is
exactly exactly right but what is this
really about for a lot of white people
it's about making themselves feel good
and this is how you end up with the saw
up Cystic self-righteous nonsense you
see at slate like slate is sort of the
bleeding edge of the solipsistic
nonsense of the white walk left it's
really incredible there's a piece I need
to read you a little bit from in just a
second because it tells you what you
need to know about this mentality but
first let's talk about the fact if your
car breaks down you probably don't know
how to fix it unless you are some sort
of mechanical genius not because you
know the normal car parts are broken but
because all these cars don't have
computer systems from electronically
controlled transmissions to touchscreen
displays to dozens of sensors if your
car breaks down you're gonna pay a lot
of money for it unless you have a car
show it's why I have car shield car show
has affordable protection plans that can
save you thousands of bucks for a
covered repair including computers GPS
Electronics and more the people at car
shell to understand payment flexibility
is an absolute must monthly plans can be
customized to your needs with rates as
low as 99 bucks a month no long term
contracts or commitments car shield will
give you options others won't you get to
choose your favorite mechanic or
dealership to do the work car shell will
take care of the rest they offer they
also offer complimentary 24/7 roadside
assistance and rental car while your car
is being fixed and this is really really
convenient stuff there's no reason for
you to spend a fortune on fixing your
car when you could just go out and get
car shield right now for as low as
ninety nine month you can protect
yourself from surprises and save
thousands for a covered repair call
eight hundred car six thousand mention
code been or visit car shield calm use
code Bend to save 10% that's car shield
comm code been a deductible may apply
again that's call eight hundred car six
thousand mentioned code been or car
shield calm use code been to save ten
percent okay in just a second we're
going I have to tell you about you know
what why quote white oak liberals are
doing to repent to re-establish their
own moral authority in just one second
first if you're not already ideally
where remember you should consider
getting a reader's pass today Lee Weyer
calm it's a great value for just three
bucks a month and when you sign up you
get that first month for only 99 cents
you also get access to our mobile app
articles had free and access to
exclusive editorials like this one ten
problematic leftist films that could use
warning labels or better yet we could
just laugh at their absurdity we have
tons of great stuff really like a lot of
great stuff over with the readers pass
including a lot of my myth-busting and
put up a lot of my new meth bust errs up
at the Daily wire readers pass if you
haven't checked out our readers pass
already go to daily we're calm sign up
for just a buck you are listening so the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say this is all about the white
liberals feeling better about themselves
that's it's really what so much of this
is about here is just a pathological
case in point there's a piece called I
think I've screwed up the way my kids
think about race by a woman named
Michelle Herman over at Slate comm okay
and this is one of their kind of Dear
Abby it's like dear woke guidance person
dear woke guidance counselor dear Karen
feeding my family is white we live in a
predominantly white neighborhood however
our kids twin boys went to a local
public charter elementary and middle
school that was very diverse when it was
time for high school our twins were
lucky enough to have their closest
friends from elementary and middle
school attend the same school each of
the boys had a diverse group of friends
and they were taken aback as freshmen in
high school by the way other kids sat at
tables and Sam raised clusters the kids
who'd gone to our small middle school
where's handles were assigned my grade
continued to hang out at lunch together
as a mixed group now my sons have
graduated and their closest friends are
still a mix of black Hispanic and white
kids I've never been concerned about the
kids having any issues around race but
one of our sons mentioned recently how
irritated he is by the form he has to
fill out regarding a college roommate he
has to specify his race and all of the
profiles of potential roommates he views
also include race he says all he cares
about is if they are male or female and
what their interests are he doesn't care
about race with everything going on in
the u.s. right now I'm doing more
reading on racism and if I'm
understanding correctly not caring about
race is almost as bad as focusing only
on race should he care what race his
friends are or is it okay for him to not
even care or notice is there something
we should be doing or talking to our
kids about before they go to college or
is it too late are they just as racist
as someone who has only white friends or
am i worrying about nothing okay then
making a mountain out of a molehill
making a mountain out of an anthill
that's what this person calls themselves
do you're making a mountain out of an
anthill I don't believe for a second you
think your kids are racist so this feels
like a disingenuous question one meant
to challenge the idea that not caring
about we're not noticing races itself
racist so I will say this not caring
about or noticing race is a privilege
reserved for people who are white black
and brown people in the u.s. do not have
that luxury and not just with everything
going on right now but ever and that's
the thing you should be talking to your
kids about for starters as the
sociologist Megan Underhill who studies
race and family has said white people
aren't outside of race they're at the
top of the racial hierarchy dismissing
or downplaying this reality only
perpetuates inequity and violence it's
great your kids have grown up with a
diverse group of friends are not to be
the norm but non racism is only the
first
toward a more just society anti-racism
requires more of us I trust that your
sons would embrace the opportunity to
learn how to take the next steps I urge
you to take them right along with your
kids you see you're evil your kids have
diverse group of friends and they don't
care what the race of the roommate is
because they're racist they're not
anti-racist enough which means that they
are this is what this is you feel better
about yourselves whoa quite awful
Reddy's making the world worse making
literally making the world worse just
tearing down statues of great Americans
and talking about how all of American
history is evil and how nothing unifies
us and how if you have a diverse group
of friends and you just tend to think of
them as your friends that's because
you're just a you're just a bad white
person you're just a bad evil white
person because black and brown people we
know have to think in terms of race but
if you're a white person you have a
bunch of black and brown friends well
you're probably a racist if you don't
see them as black and brown friends
because you have to see people in terms
of race in order to in order to what
exactly in order to what in order to
make rectification for your white guilt
hey bad has this become by the way the
UCLA politics Department is about to
condemn a white lecturer for reading the
n-word why because he read the MLK
letter from Birmingham jail which uses
the n-word so this is this is how far we
have come this is how far we have come
now this does have some real-world
consequences you know it sounds as
though this doesn't but it turns out
that ideology has consequences when you
suggest that the chief obstacle to
equality in the United States is the
system itself when you suggest that you
threat to black people in the United
States is white people and when you
suggest the only way the black people
are going to get ahead in the United
States is for white people to accept the
responsibility for every wrong in
American life and every decision made by
somebody else in American life there is
no cure there is no cure and not only
that it leads to the promulgation of
crappy policy this is what half of the
black lives matter movement has been
about is this idea that that the chief
problem facing black Americans is police
brutality okay in reality police
brutality and police racism first well
there's no evidence of systemic police
racism in the United States they do the
police all over the United States are
systemically racist the evidence of that
is incredibly scanty incredibly scanty
as far as police brutality that would be
theoretically a problem for all
Americans
and there plenty of tapes of the cops
treating white people badly and the you
can think of that that protester who got
pushed over at 75 year old man and
cracked his head on the back of crack
back of his head right white guy
police brutality not restricted to any
one race but one of the black lives
matter movement is chief arguments that
the entire system is racist and the tip
of the iceberg is policing the tip of
the iceberg is policing the disparate
crime statistics between white and black
in the United States are not a
reflection of underlying individual
criminal activity they're a reflection
of the evils of the system itself and so
the solution is to stop policing and
this is what's behind the defund the
police movement is why black lives
matter equals defund the police was
painted on the streets of Washington DC
well it turns out that actually has some
some real consequences so in the
newfound beautiful pacifistic Haven of
Chaz / chop over in Seattle they banned
the cop heard the cops were not allowed
to come in because autonomous it's the
it's the capitol whole autonomous zone
they called it now be the occupied
protest but originally it was the
Capitol Hill autonomous zone well over
the weekend somebody got shot and died
their officers responded around 2:30
a.m. local time to a report of shots
fired at Kelly Anderson Park which is
inside chaz according to a police
statement officers attempted to locate a
shooting victim but were met by a
violent crowd that prevented officers
safe access to the victims according to
a statement from the cops police said
they were later informed that chop
medics had taken the two victims to a
hospital officers then went to
Harborview Medical Center where they
were told a 19 year old male had died
from his injuries police had the other
shooting victim a male remains in the
hospital with life threatening injuries
police later released footage of the
incident the video shows the initial
moments of the shooting in which the
sound of shots was captured on security
cameras later body camera video showed
protestors confronting police as they
arrived at the scene that video shows at
least eight officers entering the area
some carrying shields as protesters yell
at them an officer can be heard saying
please move out of the way so you can
get to the victim oh we are trying to do
is get to the victim and provide them
aid a bystander can be heard yelling you
don't belong here they're gone
the victim is gone another says put your
effing guns down so literally two people
were shot I believe that the I believe
that the guy who died was black is my
understanding but the chief threat to
black people is the police who are
coming in to deal with this problem
according to the protesters over in Chaz
a later clip shows police leaving as
members of the public continue to yell
at them some can be seen holding back
other protesters from the officers as
they head toward their patrol cars as
the officer wears that wearing the
camera pulls away heels move move out of
the way as protesters apparently hit the
car
andraz Simone who is the alleged warlord
of this of this place he's upset about
this he tweeted out that this is the
fault of the cops obviously everything
is the fault of the cops we ban the cops
it's their fault we let them in it's
their fault no matter what happens we
are high the warlord of chad's I'm not
responsible he tweeted out medics
refused to help even after people in the
chop bag they let our bro bleed out for
30 minutes till he died F politics F
your corrupt system C you are our u PT
ok good stuff there from from R as
Simone
so the autonomous zone established in
defiance of the evil police calls the
cops as soon as there's a problem and
then bar the cops from actually entering
and it's the fault of the cops do you
feel like maybe this has nothing to do a
lot of these protests have nothing to do
with actually achieving good things on
behalf of black people and have
everything to do with castigating the
system and a lot of this has to do with
that there so there are many
good-hearted people who are protesting
who believe obviously that they are
improving the system and there are
systemic improvements that can be made
when it comes to police brutality but
the the outsized insanity that leads to
people cheering on Chaz shirring down
the tearing down of statues that is not
going to improve the lives of black
Americans it is not I mean here's the
proof over an over the weekend or over
last week there were 51 shootings in New
York 51 there are at least 24 victims in
18 incidents on Sunday alone according
to the NYPD maybe that has something to
do with the fact that the NYPD has been
absolutely neutered by Bill de Blasio
maybe that has something to do with the
facts that the that the mayor and the
and the media have decided the cops are
the bad guys there is also by the way a
shooting spree in Minneapolis so
remember that time when Minneapolis
basically decided to disestablish its
Police Department it turns out that when
you get rid of the cops
you're gonna want those cops back as I
as I said last week you're gonna miss
those cops when they are gone who thinks
this has improved the lives of the
people in Minneapolis the police were
the actual bad guys the system is the
actual bad system also over the weekend
there were more gun shots fired at the
Atlanta
Wendy's which is exciting stuff remember
that Wendy's where-where-where a shot
Brooks was shot because he was sleeping
behind the wheel of a car and the driver
drive through the lane the wind he's
called the cops by the way black on
Wendy's they called the cops the the
cops arrived had a conversation with
ratio at Brooks for like 25 to 40
minutes and then he wrestled two of them
to the ground stole the Taser shot one
of the cops of the Taser tried to shoot
the other cop with the Taser no shot for
his trouble
and then people tried to burn down the
Wendy's well now there was more shooting
that broke out at Wendy's over the
weekend so things are going great in
Atlanta well done everybody here's what
that sounded like people running away
because a shooting broke out at the
Wendy's again and that's excellent stuff
yeah it turns out that this new world it
kind of sucks and it blows it turns out
this is this new world that is being
created by the left it's kind of
terrible and actually makes room for
people to act horribly it makes room for
people to act horribly another instance
of somebody acting horribly over the
weekend according to the New York Post
there was a Michigan rapper he shot a
viral video of his brother slugging a
white guy inside a Macy's department
store and this is this one absolutely
viral and then so the here is here's the
video of the guy just walking I'm just
slugging a white dude in a Macy's
department store and he's just beating
the hell out of the eye right well
according to the according to the guy's
brother who posted the video he said
that this guy called them the n-word
okay Ft Quay said his brother acted on
instinct that his violent reaction was
spur-of-the-moment he said she want
people to know the real story of really
what's happened and what's in the
description of me and my brother just
walking into Macy's just minding our own
business and yes we made a petty joke
and asked the guy was the shirt too
little when he could have asked me he
was just being funny and just the fact
of the remark he said that we all heard
and just what else were we supposed to
do in this day and age in time he didn't
know what else to do that was just his
instinct the video shows quais brother
who is black punching a white store
employee and knocking him to
then hitting him twice more as he tries
to crawl crawl away
Flynn police launched an investigation
after the videos posted on social media
they said they're looking for Quay and
his brother
Macy's officials identified the white
man as a store employee and called the
attacked unprovoked naturally the get
out of jail free card for an unprovoked
attack is that you suggest that the
person used the n-word which makes full
sense I'm sure that this happened where
a genevese Valley Center Mall in Flint
Township in Flint Michigan which is a
heavily black area I'm sure that this
this employee has never seen a black
person before at Macy's and just decided
to use the n-word randomly out of
nowhere or alternatively Macy's has all
of this on tape and when Macy says this
is an unprovoked attack that's cause it
was an unprovoked attack but as so long
as you invoke the history of racism of
the United States all bad behavior is
apparently approved all bad behavior is
okay people are tweeting this out with
sympathy for the guy who is knocking
down the who is knocking down the Macy's
store employee not kidding that's it
that's an actual thing what a wonderful
country we're creating for ourselves
meanwhile by the way you know how
Atlanta is basically burning down
Howland's has a disaster area and police
are walking off the job the good news is
the Democratic Party is improving all of
this the Atlanta mayor is now being
asked whether she ought to be the vice
presidential pick for Joe Biden on Jake
Tapper show on CNN so things aren't
going beautifully here Vice President
Joe Biden has said that his first
criteria for picking a running mate is
that the person be ready on day one to
be President of the United States you
are a contender to become Joe Biden's
vice presidential nominee are you ready
on day one to be President of the United
States yes but I also think that Joe
Biden has the right to pick whomever he
wants to work alongside him and to serve
as his vice president final capper on
today's stupid news so everyone will be
and the left will not escape this the
left will not escape this there's not a
single person on the Left who's going to
escape this unless they simply bowed to
the whims of the white well the white
woke priesthood and and the and the
people like Nicole Hannah Jones over at
the New York Times Jimmy Kimmel has to
go on vacation now Jimmy Kimmel is going
on vacation because people are pointing
out that back during the man show 1999
to 2004 he put on blackface and played
Karl Malone and also did a parody of The
Oprah Winfrey Show called Oprah Jim free
so apparently he has cancelled now as
well everyone gets canceled everyone
gets canceled because the revolution
must be perpetual and the only way
America can ever be better is for the
revolution to continue a pace and all
the heroes of yesterday will be made
into villains today and all the heroes
of today by the way I should note right
now they'll be made into villains
tomorrow
rogues Fierro is one of the first people
to the guillotine so enjoy yourselves
getting because you've decided that the
equal rights that Americans fought and
paid in blood and died for and that
black Americans fought for those those
rights that black Americans spent
centuries fighting for and were achieved
those rights in the end they just
weren't all that important the only real
thing that matters is virtue signalling
and tearing down the system of Rights
itself and wasn't what an ugly country
we aren't creating okay we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content including president
Trump's big Tulsa rally didn't go all
that great will explain why plus we'll
be getting to an incredible story of the
Amazon now barring particular points of
view will guess all that you're
listening to the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel white house key technical
producer Austin Stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
Tsai events audio is mixed by micro
Romina hair and makeup is by Nika Geneva
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
black lives matter founders admit
they're trained Marxist organizers
rioters toppled more statues and
president Trump holds his first rally
since the wolf Lou lockdowns check it
out on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]